I am I'm consistently impressed by
reddit I'd say on a near weekly basis by
little little things whether it's I
absolutely love seeing the photoshop
jobs that people do not of silly cats
but of redditors who are like I have
this photo of like my mom this is the
last photo I took with her she was in
the hospital can any of you clean this
photo op can you get rid of the tubes
can go to the oxygen canister and to see
in comments redditors you know I'm sure
either professional or at least amateurs
of the professional ability coming back
within minutes with improved photoshop's
improving photos doing that sort of
thing for a total stranger for a virtual
stranger on the internet that kind of
online spontaneous altruism happens
weekly on reddit and I adore that the
most significant one well the easiest
one to quantify was the fundraiser that
red organized for Direct Relief
not-for-profit working to help disaster
relief in Haiti after the earthquake and
that was a scenario where the reddit
community on its own accord was bubbling
up stories about the most effective way
to give money turns out you know while
it's easy to text the number two the Red
Cross or two yella Haiti those may not
be the most efficient organizations to
give money to whether it's because
they've outstanding debt obligations
they're using the money to pay off or
what have you I think I think this is
something that also intrigues me from
more of a future of philanthropy
perspective because I think there are
plenty of geeks and this whether it's my
experience with this reddit fundraiser
or my experience with red pig there are
plenty of geeks who want to give and but
the most important thing really comes
down to accountability and that's a
great a great opportunity for a lot of
non-for-profits because the internet
makes it so much easier to be
accountable in a way that was just
difficult just a pain in the ass 15 or
20 years ago and so to go back to direct
relief we got in touch with some folks
there their social media guy happened to
not only be a redditor but someone I
went to college with Steve and I both
went to college with and so we had some
basic questions you know can you all
provide us with photos of a lot of the
medical supplies are going in can you
guarantee that a hundred percent of
every dollar editor gives goes to
medical stuff or whatever supplies that
you need at the moment and can you also
do an interview let us let reddit
organize and ask me anything interview
this is a famous reddit thing that goes
on fascinating
reviews and have actual direct relief
workers and volunteers answer the
question they said yes to all of them we
said great so I threw up a quick blog
post chose a silly geeky number based on
pie 30 1400 they to fundraise as the
goal they read it cleared it in a couple
hours and so I figured all right let's
double it there was an interesting math
joke in there that Chris told me about 2
pi but we doubled it and they broke that
in another few hours and and the final
number was actually a mark set by our
editor who wanted who came up with this
idea it was to surpass the amount of
money that redditors gave to one another
and what was I think a Guinness World
Record largest Secret Santa contest so
they chose this number I figured if we
can give this much to one another in
secret santa projects we can at least
give this much to direct relief because
they've been so good to us in terms of
you know how they're using the money
effectively and candidly and so read it
in total and you can go check this out
raised over 180 thousand dollars for
Haiti and to see something like that
happen we're obviously a lot of people
are interested but the CETA actually
come into action and they come into play
was just wonderful and we you know the
good folks at dig actually Jay and Kevin
very kindly jumped on to this kind of
competition we wanted to create say who
could fund raise you know to use this
silly dig versus reddit competition or
whatever have you the rivalry to to
actually try to fund raise as much money
as possible Direct Relief so it was it
was just a great experience all in all
it was was an example of the reddit
community even with all of its scale
showing its ability to actually do stuff
and in this case to do really really
good stuff and the internet it never
ceases to amaze me and this was probably
the one of the most impressive things
I've ever seen
yes the well this is the this is the
trouble at the Internet I mean this is
the great thing this is one of the great
virtues but also the sort of trouble
with it is that we we realized when we
created reddit this was this was our
baby and we like Stephen I really loved
and adored the site but ultimately all
of the value on the site the real reason
people come to reddit is not has nothing
to do with stever make maybe a little
bit to do it steeps algorithm but it has
to with the community and what one
realizes there is that we're not in
control of the community in any way
shape or form I we have no power over it
and and so we've lost this total control
the benefit of it is we get these
fantastic things to happen spontaneously
these giant movements and we get other
things where it's just a little
frustrating to see people organizing to
use the power the power that that which
is a fairly genuine parts just do silly
asinine things the we take a recent
example hopefully you can edit this down
as I pause to think of a recent example
Oh would it read it do oh okay all right
so more broadly the there was there was
an appalling appalling video shot I'm
not even guess where I don't think it
was in the u.s. because I don't think
they were speaking English but maybe
some like I've it okay so there was a
video posted to the Internet of a young
girl tossing puppies into a river this
made the rounds on 4chan this made the
rounds on reddit I'm sure that's made
the rounds everywhere else it was an
appalling video and then it was just
this young girl sort of callously
chucking puppies into a river awful
awful awful stuff and it's very easy to
get angry about that and and for lots of
very good reasons it seems redditors and
the intern in general has a very soft
spot for animals but that aside there
are there are reasonable ways to deal
with that sort of thing and then there
are unreasonable ones and actually our
community manager Eric we're in a really
good post about
this kind of mob mentality and
chastising it for for doing things for
doing things in an inappropriate way in
the in that there are there are ways
that the anonymous masses of the
internet can do really great and
interesting stuff and go through good
channels like the authorities like you
know law and order does have a place and
and when it comes to sort of terrorizing
virtually someone as despicable as that
girl was for doing that that does not
seem just and it seems that there are
better ways for her to get justice than
to terrorize her online or to find out
and reveal all kinds of personal info so
Eric wrote a much better piece that I'm
explaining right now but I'm sure if you
google it you'll find it as user names
huy priest but it there is there is
though that reality that you know even
me saying this into a camera now
broadcast at some point over the
intertubes will have no impact frankly
because we don't and I don't delude
myself into thinking I have that kind of
controller that anyone really does
because this is just the magic of the
internet it's just in my own little
opinion piece my editorial here it's
just not cool and I mean it's certainly
awful awful awful awful to think it's a
little and see someone doing that to
some puppies but that's they're just
ways to do things and that is not
appropriate